people always have given me trouble for
going to clubs so why don't I just open
my own boss [ __ ] Lindsay Lohan's Beach
Club cast dishes on what it's like to
have lilo as a boss at the red carpet
premiere party of their new MTV show for
a long time so what is it like it's like
being a partner with the business woman
I'm a business man and we're like drink
businesses together
nothing like two months or two I don't
think about lives as a celebrity you
need to realize that you know very
transparent she's very like straight out
so they were honored she doesn't he
knows like how to have fun but at the
same time she's like snaps back into
boss mode and she's like okay it's time
to get back to work so she's definitely
a cool boss I love working with her and
can't wait I was nervous the favor leave
but when I met her she got to be very
like open so listen to other people's
opinions and she's great she's great
she's like she's almost like a top of
all there you know she cares about you
but she's definitely willing to practice
going into it I mean obviously I grew up
watching Freaky Friday you know her on
the other side being like a boss and you
know she has come such a long way and
she is so inspiring and you know I've
learned so much
she's very like present it's kind of
like when she comes in she knows what
she wants and she goes how she wants it
done
and you have like he's one chance to
make a good impression because if it's a
bad first impression because I teaching
her mom honestly this is awesome like I
you know like I look for a boss she's
super strength super business money
oriented you don't do your job you're
gone you know like there's no oh please
another chance it's one and done so I
loved working for her I think she's
awesome
Lindsay was interesting so one of the
things that was hard for me because I'm
usually very combated and argumentative
at work I think with Lindsay is that
anyone to fight with her because I know
she would kick me off behind it right
away so I kind of had to roll with the
punches and do what she asked on time
but if you give it what she wants she's
pretty easygoing fight her on it she's
gonna shut you down
[Music]